nobody voted for rishy sunak you know
the British people didn't vote for rishy
sunak the British people didn't vote for
for Liz truss the British people didn't
vote for Theresa May so there's this IM
immense weariness with the conservative
party which will not go away and there
is nothing you can do to move the dial
on that there was one suspicion that
perhaps if inflation came down and wages
began to rise a little bit which is
always a difficult Paradox to pull off
uh the the perhaps the position would be
better for the conservative party but
there is also the feeling amongst those
who particularly up here that there's
been a sort of Palace coup while there's
no great love left for Boris Johnson the
people up here who voted overwhelmingly
for for the conservative party in 2019
now see that the conservative part is
back on its usual liberal remainer
trajectory and want to have nothing to
do with it